Ladies,
if you are dating a man and your ultimate dream is to be a homemaker,
and you have expressed this to that man,
and that man says living off of 1 income is 1. Impossible,
2 outdated,
and that it is more realistic to live off a fifty fifty,
meaning you both split the bills and the responsibilities
around the house.
Just know that is that man's way of telling you
he does not want to be a provider.
He does not have what it takes
to do what is needed to provide for you and your family.
And you don't need to ask any more questions.
You shouldn't have to convince a man, um,
to be a provider.
Some men just aren't providers,
and that's okay.
However, if your dream is to be a homemaker,
do not continue wasting your time with this type of man.
There are plenty of men out there that make this lifestyle realistic,
and they do what needs to be done.
They might work more than one job.
They might, um,
put you in a smaller home.
They might change states to, um,
a state that is more realistic to live off of one income.
You might not even be able to be fully on one income.
You might need to supplement that husband's income.
That's okay. That is okay.
There's nothing untraditional about that.
However, a masculine provider man
will always do what he needs to do
to protect and provide for His family.
Do not delude yourselves into thinking that the next step
will bring out a better version of your man.
Getting married will suddenly not make him a provider.
If you think that when you become a mother and he's a father
that he will suddenly want his wife to stay home with his kids,
that might be true for some,
but for a lot that is not.
And I see this as the case is
a lot of women think that their husband will become a better man.
Um,
I hate to break it to you,
but in the dating stage,
if he's not showing that he wants to be a provider,
then you are not gonna have a provider as a husband, most likely.
When you are dating,
really show how much family and your home will mean to you
in the future.
Really make an emphasis of that.
And, um, don't be prioritizing materialistic things such as cars,
a big house, vacations.
If you truly want to be a homemaker,
express this to him and I promise you, a god fearing,
masculine provider man will give you the world.